Ви мене чуєте? Вибачте, беззвучний режим. Так краще? А так? Так добре?
Так, тепер це наші будні. Але коли усі у відеодзвінках, стає менше ось цього…
…і цього…
Мені стало цікаво: а чи сповільнить це зміни клімату? І чи можемо ми робити з дому щось, окрім відеочатів?
І якими будуть відеодзвінки майбутнього?
Ми у космосі!
Нумо, перевіримо!
Розмовляти один з одним віч-на-віч, перебуваючи у зовсім різних місцях.
Люди прагнуть цього віддавна. Причому ще до появи науково-фантастичних фільмів.
Від 19-го століття.
Перший комерційний відеотелефон з'явився доволі рано. Так званий "Picture Phone" задумувався передусім для бізнес-зустрічей.
Але коштував, за сьогоднішньою вартістю, близько 800 євро на місяць за якихось 30 хвилин розмови.
Відеодзвінки були супердорогими, прилади складними в обслуговуванні, і майже ні в кого їх не було.
До кого тоді дзвонити? Аж поки не з'явився інтернет. Відеотелефонія стала доступною для широких мас.
Завдяки покращенню інтернет-трафіку, падінню цін на нього та компаніям на кшталт Skype її отримали мільйони людей. А тоді…
…пандемія коронавірусу … +++   …глобальна пандемія коронавірусу… +++   …коронавірусна криза… +++   Люди в усьому світі працюють з дому.
Пандемія коронавірусу – поворотний момент для відеотелефонії.
Від початку пандемії я провів у цій коробці неймовірно багато часу.
Як і всі інші. Кількість завантажень програм для відеотелефонії стрімко зросла.
До прикладу, якщо у 2019-му році Zoom скачали 30 мільйонів разів, то у 20-му - 500 мільйонів разів. У конкурентів ситуація схожа.
Відеодзвінки пробили стелю. Тоді як авіалінії пішли на дно.
Авіагалузь нині дуже, дуже вразлива…
Це Річард Маслен, аналітик міжнародної маркетингової компанії у сфері авіації.
Не думаю, що хтось у авіаційній галузі минулого року збагнув,
наскільки драматичними насправді будуть наслідки коронавірусу для цієї галузі.
До пандемії ринок авіаперевезень зростав - тим боліснішим став його обвал.
Повернення до повсякдення ще далеко. Принаймні поки не стануть можливими ділові авіаподорожі.
Саме вони особливо сприяють оборотам галузі, адже для відряджень квитки часто купуються в останній момент і в дорогому "бізнес-класі".
Пандемія показала нам, що ми можемо зустрічатися з колегами та бізнес-партнерами, не виходячи з дому.
І це погані новини для авіакомпаній. Але хороші для клімату.
Відеозв'язок або, скажімо, телеприсутність має величезний потенціал для зменшення викидів парникових газів.
Це Пол Дікінсон. Він заснував неурядову організацію CDP, яка з'ясовує обсяги викидів СО2 кожної компанії.
Дікінсон - фанат відеоконференцій уже 24 роки…
Я вивчав інформатику і помітив, що відео потенційно може зекономити поїздки - шлях до офісу чи навіть на ділову зустріч.
Я склав список усіх професій у світі. І думаю, що половину видів діяльності можна робити по відеозв'язку.
А уникаючи половини усіх поїздок, ми також уникаємо половини викидів від автомобільного,
залізничного та, звичайно, повітряного руху.
Пасажирські подорожі спричиняють близько 13 відсотків усіх техногенних викидів.
За оцінками Пола Дікінсона, можна було б уникнути половини цих викидів, якщо відмовитись від подорожей на користь відеодзвінків.
Але, звичайно, відеодзвінки теж спричиняють витрати енергії, а її виробництво призводить до шкідливих викидів.
Так, інформаційні технології спричиняють збільшення викидів. І це потрібно враховувати.
Але вони незначні порівняно з викидами  дорожнього руху.
Ви в Німеччині, я у Великобританії.
Якби ми зараз зустрілися в реальному житті, викиди були б значно, значно, значно більшими, ніж енерговитрати нашого відеочату.
Ми з Полом Дікінсоном говорили близько 45 хвилин. Я отримую свій інтернет через мідний кабель.
Згідно з новим дослідженням, при обробці та передачі даних виділяється три грами СО2 за хвилину.
Якби я злітав з Берліна у Лондон і назад, то спричинив би 187 кілограмів, тобто 187 000 грамів викидів.
Але як буде після пандемії? Ми повернемося до старого способу життя - будемо знову їздити на роботу та активно літати?
Чи будемо зустрічатися онлайн, як зараз?
Думаю, ми побачимо переосмислення. Люди, швидше за все, здійснюватимуть менше, зате кращих, ефективніших ділових поїздок,
де вирішуватимуть більше справ. Але кількість стане значно меншою.
Я бачу в цьому нову тенденцію. Думаю, інтенсивність руху досягла свого піку.
І ми, напевно, останнє покоління, яке так неймовірно багато в дорозі, особливо для роботи.
Причин для цього більше немає.
Але я не хочу весь час розмовляти з людьми лише через монітор. Це не одне й те саме, що зустрічатися у справжньому житті.
Насправді відеодзвінки нас дуже втомлюють. Нашому мозку бракує мови тіла іншої людини.
Його напружують безліч облич, які на нас витріщаються. І йому не дуже комфортно, коли є затримки звуку та зображення.
Але фахівці працюють над тим, щоб це змінити. Зараз я зустрінуся із засновником MeetinVR.
Не по нудному, двохвимірному відеодзвінку, а у віртуальній реальності.
Подивимось, як це працює!
Це моє віртуальне "я", мій аватар. Фірма створила його з мого фотопортрету.
Гей, Мальте, приємно бачити тебе тут. Ласкаво просимо до MeetinVR. Це наша кімната для інтерв’ю. Кава тут завжди тепла.
У віртуальній реальності немає меж, які існують у реальності.
Ми вивчаємо кожну інтеракцію, яка буває на звичайних зустрічах,
і потім намагаємось зробити її ще більш інтуїтивною та ефективною, ніж у реальності.
І це спрацьовує, оскільки у віртуальній реальності у нашому розпорядженні є надприродні сили.
Наприклад, за вухом завжди є ручка.
Ви вже намагалися витягнути ручку з-за вуха у реальності?
Так, багато разів! І це завжди дуже кумедно.
Хочу зробити якісь нотатки і помічаю… ой, я ж не в віртуальній реальності.
І розумію, що мені треба, мабуть, проводити більше часу у справжньому світі.
Крістіан-Емануель Антон вважає, що за кілька років наше життя дедалі більше переходитиме у віртуальну реальність.
Деякі корпорації вже дозволяють своїм співробітникам працювати разом у MeetinVR.
Наприклад, для спільного створення "мап думок" або для "мозкового штурму".
А інші компанії хочуть використовувати MeetinVR, щоб краще представляти свою продукцію,
пропонувати своїм клієнтам незабутні та інтерактивні враження.
Набагато легше встановити емоційний зв'язок з іншими учасниками, ніж через звичайний відеодзвінок.
І мушу визнати, це справді так. Принаймні в моєму випадку. Мені зрозуміло, що це лише ілюзія.
І все ж, у мене відчуття, що я близько до Крістіана. В реальному житті він, між іншим, має ось такий вигляд.
У майбутньому наша міміка буде також відображатися у "віртуальній реальності".
Ми будемо представлені голограмами нас самих. Точними нашими копіями.
Усе це доповнять мова тіла і відчуття присутності. Це все буде дуже захоплюючим!
Дякую, Мальте. Щасти і, сподіваюсь, до зустрічі!
Це здається божевіллям, коли прокинувся. Лише пару хвилин тому я був у цій величезній аудиторії. А зараз знову тут.
Те, що буквально пару десятиліть ще було науковою фантастикою, зараз стає реальністю.
Голограми, які передають копію тебе самого, вже існують. І так звані "роботи телеприсутності" - теж.
Гаразд, дехто зараз скаже, що це лише планшети на колесах. Але вони дозволяють на відстані пересуватися у реальному приміщенні.
І так, операції вже проводяться звідусіль.
І тут, звичайно, хочеться бути особливо впевненим у тому, що інтернет-зв'язок справді стабільний.
Ми повинні закласти основи. Нам треба обладнати волоконно-оптичними кабелями кожне домогосподарство.
Оскільки будувати дедалі більше доріг, дедалі більше автомобілів та аеропортів для поліпшення нашого спілкування - це не екологічно.
Ми не мусимо транспортувати себе. Ми маємо транспортувати наші серця, наші душі та нашу присутність.